now we turn our attention to the
Democratic Party of course their allies
in the media mob nothing but an
extension of the press office of the DNC
now remember first was Russia Russia
then a stormy stormy and then it was in
Peach and Peach [ __ ] [ __ ] Russia
Russia Russia racist racist all right so
while the hysteria shifted the goal
remain unchanged smear slander besmirch
destroyed bludgeon the trump presidency
unfortunately for them all the previous
narratives ended in failure so now the
trying something new and they're even
telling us what they're doing led by the
New York Times after first dedicating
their entire newsroom as they say to the
Russian lie conspiracy and hoax
well now the New York Times is shifting
their efforts to paint Trump and
everyone in his orbit every Republican
every conservative is a racist of course
this is not a revolutionary concept I've
been telling you and I've chronicled on
this program for years every two and
four years the left in this country will
accuse Republicans conservatives of
being racist sexist misogynist
homophobic xenophobic Islamophobic they
want to kill children they want dirty
air and water and then they want Grandma
and Grandpa to eat dog food or cat food
and then throw them over a cliff and as
we speak Democrats around the country
they are already breathlessly accusing
Trump of bigotry racism even
anti-semitism the biggest ally in
history for Israel is Donald J Trump now
these phony charges are coming from the
very same Democratic Party that is the
home to two of the most virulent
anti-semites to ever hold public office
that would be congresswoman to leave and
congresswoman Omar who are obsessed with
hating Israel they both supported the
anti-semitic BDS movement a boycott of
Israel they've compared a boycott of
Israel to a boycott of Nazi Germany they
both need an education about the horrors
of what happened in the Holocaust and
what happened in those concentration
camps they both share shared this
anti-semitic content on social media
including that cartoon from a Holocaust
denier came in second in an Iranian
Holocaust denying contest
or not existed they were both also
blocked from entering Israel on a trip
planned by what was a radical Islamic
group that praised suicide bombers and
congresswoman Omar claim that lawmakers
were controlled by quote Jewish money
all about the Benjamins baby she also
tweeted quote Israel is hypnotized the
world may Allah awaken the people and
help them see the evil doings of Israel
comparing Israel to Nazi Germany Wow and
congresswoman to leave actually wrote
for the biggest anti-semite in the
country's newspaper louis farrakhan's
anti-semitic racist newspaper and to top
it all off they are both good friends
with the vile activist Linda Sarsour
remember she's the one that supports
Sharia law and blamed her bad reputation
on the Jewish media so tonight a simple
question to all the Democrats all of you
in the media mob accusing Trump of
anti-semitism you know the guy that
recognized the sovereignty of the Golan
Heights after so many of the president's
promise to move the embassy to Jerusalem
that Donald Trump you're accusing him of
anti-semitism where is your widespread
condemnation of these two Congress women
well that's right the left's accusations
against Trump well it matters if he does
it on the other side that's selectively
fake phony outrage like Hillary Clinton
if she aligns herself with Russian lies
to impact an election that's fine
she obstructs justice that's fine it's
like Oh bludgeon Cavanagh to hurt Trump
but don't even talk about the lieutenant
governor of the Commonwealth of Virginia
it's a shameful display of hypocrisy and
a double standard
now just today an editor for the New
York Times he was forced to apologize
for tweets that he had sent out in the
past that were anti-semitic and racist
and in April don't forget the Times was
forced to apologize for publishing a
horrible anti-semitic cartoon picturing
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu as
Trump's seeing-eye dog do as I say not
as I do pretty common on the left for
example we just learned that many 20/20
Democrats will call for a boycott of
uber and lyft they spent hundreds of
dollars on these very same car services
even on the day they proposed the
boycott Wow now today by the way the
most insane development and the
2020 race while that came from Bernie
Sanders the angry socialist himself was
a few hours ago he officially unveiled
his version of the green New Deal and
the contents of pretty much you'd expect
from a 77 year old angry socialist who
had his honeymoon in the Soviet Union no
more oil and gas by 2030 a life but of
our economy got magic planes that don't
emit carbon and by the way an end to all
unemployment guaranteed jobs okay and
the wish list goes on and on
so does the bill how does that get paid
for okay brace yourselves it's sixteen
point three trillion with a T dollars
the entire federal budget is four
trillion but get this
Sanders claims the plan is going to pay
for itself through taxes on oil and gas
companies reduced military spending and
a vague promise of making corporations
pay their fair share can I just put this
in context because in 2018 American oil
companies made a profit of twenty eight
billion dollars a year a lot of money
but the entire budget for the US
military is less than a trillion if you
do some basic simple math you'll find
out that bernie is about oh fourteen
trillion dollars short of his goal and
guess who's gonna pick up the bill he
says always gonna attack the oil and gas
companies corporations don't pay taxes
they pass it on to us we the American
people and if Bernie Sanders becomes
your president well your income will
virtually disappear and so will the
American economy it will dive into a
depression probably immediately if we
get rid of oil and gas and of Elizabeth
Warren gets her way well the money you
saved up in the bank that's also going
to be subject to a government
confiscation tax they call it the wealth
tax
they've already taxed you and if you're
stupid enough to save any money or lucky
enough they go on another bite at out of
the Apple called the wealth tax then
when you die they even going to take
more 40% whatever is left let's not
forget about comrade de Blasio the mayor
of New York while homeless Americans
lined the streets all over this country
too Blasio is now dedicating public
resources in New York to make sure
illegal immigrants can access public
housing in
city this all comes as creepy crazy
sleepy Uncle Joe Biden barely can draw a
crowd on the campaign trail even the New
York Times took notice of this lack of
enthusiasm on the ground and so far
without a doubt the big winner in the
Democratic primary I would say tonight
as president Donald Trump